Language is a beautiful thing the human brain
has equipped us with.
We understand and describe the experience
of life in the form of language.
It is the conduit for transmitting thoughts
and ideas from human to human, consciousness
to consciousness, producing a worldly vibration
of interconnectivity.
But language’s necessity for human social
function has possibly limited the human experience
of life.
We seem to so often forget that there is a
world beyond our current language.
A world of feelings and thoughts that go beyond
linguistic comprehension.
Did depression exist before man created a
term for it?
Did blue exist before man classified it?
Did anything exist before man identified it?
If at one point in human history there was
no word for depression, were humans still
depressed without knowing it?
What did this unawareness result in?
And what are we feeling right now without
knowing what to call it?
Without being able to identify it.
Or perhaps the opposite, what aren’t we
feeling because we haven’t yet created any
words for it?
Our understanding of life and consciousness
is facilitated by language, but our EXPERIENCE
of life and consciousness does not have to
be limited to it.
Life is not solely found in how you think
or speak about it, but also in how you feel
it.
It is this that we must understand and try
to embrace as we navigate through life’s
unknown.